democrats are being accused of hypocrisy
for protecting themselves but not their
constituents
protesters are banned on the block where
chicago mayor lori lightfoot lives
while the city sees a spike in shootings
and murders
lightfoot defended the move take a look
this is a different time like no other
and
i'm not going to make any uh excuses
for the fact that given the threats that
i personally receive
given the threats to my home and my
family i'm going to do everything i can
to make sure
that they are protected and i make no
apologies
whatsoever for that
greg you are high profile and have no
doubt received
threats in the past is there a fort
gutfeld
in the campground where you live all
those threats come from juan though
and i know where he lives so uh
okay this is the pure hypocrisy of many
in the left in which they deny the
existence of crime and mob violence
as long as it's not in their leafy
suburb well it came to her leafy suburb
and now she thinks that she gets special
protection because yeah she's a
she's a public figure but uh my
neighborhood got ravaged i know it's an
old story
but i always have to bring this up
because it's very important my
neighborhood got
ravaged and half of it is still boarded
up because of the looting
the shootings have obviously doubled in
new york city i
wonder has de blasio adjusted or
rethought his criminal strategy i don't
think so i think it's going to happen
again
a if trump wins is there going to be a
police force out there that's going to
be willing to keep
people safe from the far left rioters
and what about the floor
floyd verdict right we don't know how
that's going to go and if it doesn't go
the way that
people want it to go what's going to
happen more america
american chaos and the media will
pretend it doesn't happen
because they're in charge of the
race-baiting narrative
one if the mayor of chicago has a right
to the safety and sanctity of her home
do her constituents also have that same
right
i think we all do right i think that's
the idea
uh and in chicago by the way the law
says that you are not allowed
to have protests in residential
neighborhoods now trey i don't know if
that's constitutional
but i think that's the line that they
say they're upholding
i will say this i live in dc as you know
and
right now there's a fortress basically
around the white house you can't go in
lafayette square why because they say
it's for security reasons they want to
make sure there's no security issue
so it's it's this extends across the
board
uh you see this in other cities in terms
of mayors and city council members
uh but i think the whole point about
hypocrisy is pretty weak here the idea
is that we all should feel secure in our
home yeah
martha let me ask you you're a straight
shooter do you see any duplicity between
the mayors
not wanting even peaceful protests but
yet shops are being set on fire in the
city
i do i mean why why does she get
protection
and she's not pushing for protection for
these other stores these people have
owned their businesses their whole lives
who got the windows kicked in
and they've got to start over for the
urban families who don't have police
on their corners the way they used to or
some of them have just
adopted a different posture because
they're terrified of what might happen
if they actually
show up for the call and you know
something
something gets misinterpreted which does
happen in some of these cases not in all
of them some of them
are legitimate abuse in some of these
cases but you know
so those things need to be recognized in
a big way remember this is also the
mayor who
went to get her hair done when she told
everyone else that the salons needed to
be closed because she said
you know i'm the mayor you know so so i
get to do this one thing about
about um washington dc and uh jefferson
and
uh jackson square in front of the white
house i was just there the other day
i run in that area a lot it breaks my
heart one the reason that
whole thing is cordoned off is because
it's been destroyed the windows are
broken
everything is boarded up graffiti is
everywhere
they tried to pull the statue down in
the middle of that beautiful historic
place
so until we figure out a way to to keep
those areas safe
those fences are going to stay up and
you're right it's a crime
it breaks my heart to see lafayette
square park it really really does
jesse i'll give you the last one he's
got a bunker too
nice try jesse last quick word yeah
yeah because if one of those radical
antifa black lives matter ever got a
hold of trump he'd be dead that's why
he's secure juan i understand the
hypocrisy
if you're a suburban couple wearing a
pink polo shirt
you're not allowed to secure your
property but if you're a democratic
mayor in chicago
you're allowed and the other hypocrisy
is this chicago has tried to prohibit
you from owning
a handgun they're trying to prohibit you
from owning an ar-15
they don't protect businesses big and
small and they don't prosecute the
looters and the rioters
and people that attack police officers
that
is the hypocrisy